welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 released its
first public teaser footage a full six
seconds across the Disney plus Feels
Like Home promo it also includes some
shots of secret Invasion Mandalorian
season 3 Riri Williams screaming let's
go at us again and more from the house
of mouse my obsession with the Loki
series began nearly three years ago with
just three seconds from a Disney plus
Super Bowl spot I'm gonna burn this
place to the ground and remember I got
nine freaking minutes out of that even
though the line itself was cut from the
final version of the episode let us
react to this promo and break down the
new shots of Loki season 2 that we can
see in it roll the clip you ready for an
adventure yes oh
23 on Disney plus I'm excited for that
new stories oh it's just the beginning
fellow
[Music]
people over the top don't you think I
don't think so there's only one place
and so much more Disney plus okay okay
okay okay okay so it sounds like they
use Tom Hiddleston as the narrator for
all of this and I guess I don't really
care if it sounds like an episode of The
Great British baking show I am here for
Loki being the voice of all of Disney
Plus in fact I'm pretty sure Noel
Fielding is a Loki variant so our first
shot of Loki season two shows Sophia
demartino as Sylvie lounging on his sofa
in a record store spacing out as she
listens to some music on headphones now
there is this little monkey playing the
guitar figurine behind her and yeah I
actually took the time to track down
this this is a vintage 50s toy from
Japanese toy maker Alps made of tin and
bells batteries go in the little stereo
drawer and this monkey strums the guitar
and sways and rocks his head out as his
feet tap in little orange shoes now
normally he has a little green Sombrero
that goes on his head but like Woody
with these old collector toys the
accessories off and get lost if only you
had your hand stitched poly vinyl
and I am now sipping them hard with Miss
minutes I hope they fall in love now
this moment with Sylvie looks to be set
sometime during the 1970s based on the
headphones she's wearing also silby has
the same jacket and the same haircut
that she has in the set photos in which
she wears an orange 70s McDonald's
uniform so presumably she is unwinding
after a long stressful day working at
fast food but how does this Sylvie
connect with the Sylvie we saw at the
end of season one remember she had just
killed he remains in the Citadel and
caused the sacred timeline to rupture
one theory is that that Sylvie could
have actually ended up overtaking the
TVA and become the villain variant Kate
Dickey is playing in season two and that
selfie could be just using the facade of
Kang in that big statue to instill fear
and discipline among the TBA Rank and
file which would leave the Loki and
Mobius having to track down another
Sylvie but it's also possible that this
is the same Sylvie and she's just
swallowing in defeat working for
McDonald's in the 70s and hanging out
with her monkey brain then we get a shot
of Loki in the TVA cafeteria I believe
this was the scene from the trailer I
saw in d23 where Loki tells Mobius I
don't want you to think I'm the bad guy
in all this and Moby says who says you
are and Loki response Iron Man Captain
America Hulk Black Widow Hawkeye Bill
Coulson Thanos Nick Fury my father my
brother Miss minutes you and Moby it's
just drugs and goes this is the same
version of Loki with his hair slicked
back but we now see in an all orange
room only in an orange object it appears
to be either taking notes on or maybe
scanning his thumb in its blood for
identification just because like the way
he moves up his hand makes it look like
it pricked his thumb now I thought the
subject might be a Tandy space shot game
from 1982 with part of the view screen
removed then again this object looks a
lot bigger than a Tandy space shot
actually was or maybe Tommy Hilton
smaller than we thought but this
object's orange color matches the bright
orange walls in the ceiling of this
bizarre looking room with a portal or
maybe a massive lens behind Loki this
could be part of the TVA that's overseen
by kehu Quan's character rumored to be
the tva's head of Technology named
oroborus named after the mythological
snake that's even its own tail now one
of the best things you can do for your
body is to drink tons of water but
nothing's less satisfying than just
drinking a glass of lame old plain water
it's like the definition of boring but
if you use air up you could make every
sip of water taste like really good
oh now see that that's good water I mean
it is just regular water but it tastes
like mango passion fruit because this
ain't no regular water bottle this is
air up air up is an easy way to make
staying hydrated less boring it adds
flavor to your water with scent alone so
you can get all the water you need and
all the flavor you want no added powders
or sugars or anything it's really easy
you just take one of these flavor pods
you pop it on and if you're ready to
taste the magic of scent flavor pull the
pot up to activate the flavor announce
it
see the magic happens when air bubbles
carry the flavor from the Pod through
the straw and enable your brain to
experience the scent as taste it's that
easy it's so insane how this works and a
sidebar mango passion fruit is my go-to
flavor because it tastes tropical which
makes me feel tropical which makes me
think I'm on vacation and trust me if
you were me you would agree with me and
if you wanted to break from the Flavor
and just want plain water all you gotta
do is push the body back down see easy
there you go regular water though it's
the same liquid an air up makes a great
gift right now there are a ton of
discounted house holiday bundles on
Arab's website that make perfect
stocking stuffers for everybody on your
list because honestly everybody needs
water if you're looking for some
flavored variety the naughty list bundle
has a green air up bottle it comes with
orange
lemon the mega
pad packs there are other holiday
bundles available as well including
Barry all the way dashing Duo and B
cherry and bright if you go now you can
take advantage of air UPS holiday
special to get a bundle for yourself or
for whoever you buy gifts for for 20 to
25 off each holiday bundle has
everything you need to start your air up
Journey but they'll only be available
until December 26th so hurry up and
click the link in the description make
sure you have yours in time for the
holidays then Loki and Mobius are
dressed to the nines for some events and
movies asks a little over the top don't
you think and then we see two additional
low-keys either variants or maybe
duplications of this Loki that he casts
and then the d23 trailer one of the
Loki's response I think it's about on
now this location looks like a grimy
Alleyway off a side street there's a lit
motorcycle and overturned furniture and
other odds and ends on the walls are
written various phrases like on the left
are the words less and more maybe less
is more and then in the middle why then
by mobius's head piss off and then on
the right the word stop but then there's
also the sign in the upper right reading
to let or maybe toilet and then at the
bottom of that sign Richard something
could be Ellison Richard Ellison is an
English cricketer during the 80s it
could be Richard Eli and Son Richard
Eli's over why wasn't American
Progressive in the early 20th century
who advanced causes and organized labor
but it could also be Richard Eliason Co
with Elias and Company being the name of
the gift shop in Disney Parks Elias
Disney being Walt's father Elias was
Walt's middle name so yeah I'm trying to
figure out where this is but based on
the Loki's tuxedos that kind of formal
wear with the thrilled shirts and the
floppy bow ties was really popular
during the 1970s so it might be
connected to Sylvie's era then lastly
there's a real quick shot of Loki free
falling through the TVA ah this poor guy
always having to keep falling and
falling and falling
foreign
I have been falling
for 30 minutes Siri it looks like he's
dropping through the tva's main Central
Plaza that Mobius unveiled to him in
episode one here he is wearing the same
costume and weapon holsters that he was
wearing when they confronted eliaith and
he remains at the end of season one in
the same outfit he was wearing at the
end of that season when silly pushed him
into the warp CVA and he ran into Mobius
and B15 who had no memory of him and he
looked up to find the Kang statue so
here he might have jumped to a vape
capture or evade pruning from the other
TVA members until he has a chance to let
the corona monitors know that he's not a
threat either way I just love that
season two is gonna pick up right where
season one left off in the same scene
the same moment just like how season one
picked up with Loki from the same moment
during the time heist in Avengers end
game so if you think about it from this
Loki's perspective he went from trying
to get the Tesseract during the Battle
of New York in that first Avengers movie
getting arrested Tony Stark having a
heart attack in front of him and then a
tiny shrunken man coming out of nowhere
and kicking a suitcase to another Tony
Stark to Hulk knocking out that Tony
Stark to this tesseracts getting to
Loki's feet and then Loki using it to go
to Mongolia and then getting arrested by
a TVA that he didn't know existed and
then going through everything we saw in
Loki season 1 2 immediately now falling
plummeting this guy's always falling
deeper and deeper down the rabbit hole
and I think he's had by far the most
interesting life story of any MCU
character that's all because the
craziest of the [ __ ] happened in like
the most recent month of his life now
hopefully we'll get a full trailer
coming soon because I'm telling you when
I saw d23 was my favorite MCU footage
what we see here doesn't even scratch
his surface you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you